안녕하세요. BSN 빌딩 투자 강의를
시작하도록 하겠습니다. 제 소개를 좀
드리면 18살에 공인 중개사 자격증을
취득을 해서 지금 BSN 대표로
활동하고 있습니다. 중개법인이랑
건축사무소 건설 면허도 취득해서 따고
있고 빌딩과 관련된 모든 일을
한다라고 보시면 될 거 같고요.
최근에 거래된 통계를 좀 준비를
했어요. 빌딩 투자하는데 가장 큰
단점이 뭔지 아세요, 여러분? 바로
황금성입니다. 빌딩이 잘 안 팔려요.
아파트 같은 경우에는 가격만 낮춰도
잘 팔리는데 빌딩은 안 팔립니다. 몇
개월이 걸리기도 하고 몇 년이
걸리기도 하고 진짜 영영 안 팔릴
수도 있어요. 그래서 여러분들이
빌딩을 투자한다라고 했을 때는 잘
팔리는 곳이 어딘지를 봐야 됩니다.
어떤 지역이 거래가 좀 많이 되는지를
봐야 되는데 그런 데이터들을 제가 좀
준비를 했습니다. 요거 같은 경우에는
서울시를 다 준비를 했고 서울시
내에서 강남구가 제일 거래가 많이
되고 뭐 중구나 종로구 뭐 마포구나
최근에는 뭐 성동구 거래가 좀 많이
돼 가고 있고 더 나아가서는 동별로
좀 봐야 돼요. 동별로도 이제
거래량이 다르거든요. 예를 들어서
개포동이나 도곡동은 거래가 많이 안
됩니다. 물론 이제 아파트는 굉장히
좋지만 빌딩 투자하기에는 좋은 동네는
아니에요. 이게 동별로도 봐야 돼요.
어느 정도 금액대가 거래가 많이
되는지 봐야 됩니다. 예를 들어서
마포 석유도 홍대 지역 같은 경우에는
금액이 100억이 넘어가면 또 잘 안
팔리기도 하거든요. 그래서 강의 때
자세하게 설명드릴 예정이에요.
금액대별 거래량이랑 그다음에 건축
연도별 그래서 건물 오래된게 되게
많거든요. 그러다 보니까 임대 수익이
좀 많이 안 나와요. 좀 이렇게 임대
수익 안 나오는 건물들을 저렴하게
매입해서 뭐 재임대를 한다든지 뭐
리모델링을 한다든지 신축해 가지고
가치를 좀 올릴 수 있는 방법들이
있긴 하거든요. 그런 것들을 좀
중점적으로 알려 드릴 거예요. 대부분
다 이제 빌딩 투자한다 그러면 당장의
수익률 그리고 뭐 임차인이 어떤
임차인인지 되게 중요하게 생각해서
그거 보고 투자하시는 분들 많은데
그거 보고 잘못 투자했다가 잘못된
사례들이 워낙 많습니다. 이런 실패
사례를 유튜브로 올릴 순 없어요.
제가 강의 때 그런 실패 사례들을 좀
많이 말씀드리거든요. 그리고 빌딩
투자할 때 가장 중요한 기본적인
상황들을 확인을 해야 됩니다. 일단은
토지 이용 계획 확인해야 되고 건축물
대장 확인해야 되고 그리고 등기 사항
전부 증명서를 확인해야 되는데 이런
내용들을 왜 확인해야 되는지를 당위때
좀 말씀드리거든요. 그래서 그게
기본입니다. 그 저도 아직까지 건물
볼 때 평단가랑 뭐 그런 거 보는
거보다는 토지 이용 계획부터 봐요.이
땅이 뭔지요. 그래서 그 땅의 가치가
있는지 그리고이 건물이 최대로
활용하고 있는지 없는지를 먼저 검토를
합니다. 그래서 제가 빌딩 검토할 때
해야 되는 부분을 진짜 1부터
10까지 좀 알려 드려요. 그래서
그런 것들을 좀 강의 때 많이 다룰
예정입니다. 그래서 앞으로 빌딩 시장
좀 전망을 좀 말씀을 드리는데 뭐
지금 거래량이 좀 많이 늘어났습니다.
그래서 실제로 계약이 굉장히 좀 많이
나오고 있고 그리고 빌딩은 금리와
연관이 굉장히 좀 많이 돼 있어요.
그래서 금리가 최근에 좀 많이
내려가서 빌딩 투자에 좀 관심이
많아지신 거 같습니다. 아파트
투자자분들도 워낙 요즘에 규제가 심기
때문에이 빌딩 쪽으로 좀 많이
넘어왔거든요. 제가 봤을 때는 뭐
올해 하반기도 그렇고 내년도 거래량이
좀 더 상승하지 않을까 그렇게 예상을
합니다. 그리고 뭐 건축 자재나 이런
가격이 좀 많이 상승을 해서 뭐
신축이나 리모델링 공급이 좀 되게
많이 어려워지고 있고 그리고 최근에
제일 문제가 뭐냐면 임대가 안
됩니다. 요즘에 뭐 자영업자분들 되게
어려운 상태고 작년 같은 경우에는
폐업률이 100만 건이 넘었잖아요.
그래서 그 정도로 많은 업체들이 많이
폐업하고 있습니다. 임대 같은 경우엔
지금 시장이 좀 좋지 않아요. 그러다
보니까 거래량도 오르는데데만 오르고
임대도 되는 곳만 됩니다. 그래서
제가 강의 때 어떤 지역의 건물이 좀
잘 팔리고 어떤 지역의 건물이 가격이
좀 많이 오르고 있고 어떤 지역이
임대가 잘되는지도 제가 강의할 때
생생하게 다루니까 여러분들 관심
가지셔도 좋을 거 같고 제일 핵심이
그거예요. 임대를 얼마에 맞출 수
있는지. 근데 그런 것들을 대부분 다
분석을 하지 못합니다. 앞으로 빌딩
투자한다라고 했을 때 법인으로
매입하는 것도 한번 공부를 좀 해야
되고 그다음에 투자는 무조건 좋은
지역 사야 돼요. 제가 고객분들한테
항상 얘기하는게 뱀의 머리가 되지
말고 용의 꼬리가 되라. 예를 들어서
뭐 성수동이다라고 하면 뭐 자양동,
송정동 막 이런데 가는게 아니라 진짜
그 연무장길 근처 거기 옆에 붙어
있는 확장이 될 만한 곳에 투자하는게
저는 더 낫다라고 생각하거든요.
투자는 무조건 주요 지역에 사야
돼요. 그래서 성수동 같은 경우에는
그런 고급 주거 시설이 많잖아요.
갤러리아 포레라든지 뭐 트리마제라든지
그런 것들이 좀 밀집되어 있고
한남동도 거기 인근의 빌리지라든지
한남 더일이라든지 그런 고급 주거
시설이 좀 많이 밀집되어 있고 거기에
거주하시는 분들이 거기 근처 좀 많이
매입하거든요. 받아줄 사람이 많은
곳에 투자를 해야 됩니다. 그래서
투자는 무조건 주요 지역에 투자를
해야 된다라고 보시면 될 거 같고
그리고 건물이 워낙 노화된게 많기
때문에 뭐 리모델링이나 신축 투자도
좀 고려를 해 봐야 됩니다. 그리고
명도 관련돼서도 말씀드리고 그리고
제일 중요한게 매입도 잘하는게
중요하지만 어떻게 운영하고 어떻게 팔
건지도 계획까지도 어 상세하게 좀
설명을 드립니다. 그리고 요거는 빌딩
투자 로드맵이라 그래서 처음부터
끝까지 어떻게 하는지를 좀 설명을
드리고 건폐율 용적률 서울시는 그래도
외우고 있어야 될 거 같거든요. 그
올해 5월부터 2종이랑 3종은
용적률을 50% 더 올려 줬어요.
그래서 이게 3년간 유효합니다. 지금
2종이랑 3종 일반 주거 지역에
만약에 건물을 사게 되는 경우에는이
혜택을 받을 수 있어요. 그래서
지금이 기회를 잘 살려서 그런
용적률을 찾을 만한 용적률을 최대로
올릴 만한 그런 건물들도 많습니다.
제가 5분 만에 외울 수 있는 방법이
있거든요. 노래 부르면서 외우는
방법이 있는데 요거는 강의 때
자세하게 들으시면 될 거 같아요.
그리고 이제 답사 갈 때 어떻게
가는지 2주차 때부터 5주차 때까지
어 답사를 진행할 예정이고 강의
시작하기 전에 저희가 조언까지 평성해
가지고 다 같이 이렇게이 강남구
내에는 다 간다라고 보시면 될 거
같고 성수라든지 한남동도 강의 끝나고
난 뒤에 만약에 원하신다면 저희가 좀
답사까지도 준비를 했습니다. 강의도
되게 좋지만 답사 만족도가 되게
좋습니다. 각자 다 다른 시각들이
있기 때문에 다 같이 이렇게 답싸
가서 볼 기회가 없거든요. 팀장이
거기 배정돼서 이제 설명도 해
주겠지만 투자 포인트를 같이 이제
참고해서 하는 건데 굉장히 좀 도움이
많이 된다라고 얘기를 많이 들었어요.
그리고 제가 항상 임대 시대 조사의
별표 10만 개 치거든요. 이게 제일
중요합니다. 요즘에 임대가 워낙 안
되기 때문에 그래서 임대가 당장은 안
나와도 개선했을 때 공실이 높은
지역에 있는 건물은 사면 안 돼요.
만약에 개선했을 때 임대 수익률이
괜찮다 뭐 이런 거를 분석을 해야
되는데 대부분은 다 주변 사례보다 좀
싸다. 인차인님 스타벅스가 들어가
있다. 그냥 그것만 보고 하시는
분들이 많은데 제일 핵심은 매매
사례뿐만 아니라 임대 시세 조사하는게
되게 중요한 포인트입니다. 그리고 뭐
수익률 계산하는 것도 빌딩 투자나
상가에 투자한다고 하는데이 계산법도
모르는 분들이 많더라고요. 기초적인
것도 좀 알려 드리고 뭐 투자 사례도
이렇게 좀 많이 준비를 했고 그래서
저희가 35기 동안 하면서 싸온
노아웃들이 굉장히 많아요. 막 너무
이론적인 얘기를 해야 되나 너무
어려운 얘기를 해야 되나 하다가 수정
보안을 굉장히 좀 많이 했습니다.
정말 빌딩 투자할 때 도움이 될 만한
그런 내용들로 좀 준비했으니까
여러분들이 지금 빌딩 당장 투자하지
않는다 하더라도 부동산 투자하는데
있어서 굉장히 좀 도움이 많이
된다라고 생각하거든요. 지금 BSN
빌딩 투자 스터디 빌딩 투자하는
스터디 중에 제일 오래됐어요. 제일
검증이 됐고 정말 많은 수강생들이
있었고 그 이후에 많이 생겨나긴
했지만 정말 진인 강의입니다.
여러분들 진짜 듣고 나서 마음에 안
드시면 환불하셔도 돼요. 그 정도로
장담하는 스터디니까 관심 있으신
분들은 들으시면 좋을 것 같습니다.
영상 여기까지 하겠습니다.
감사합니다.
[음악]